et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
benoit harel fondateur de l'association
pour la messe bonsoir benoît rennes
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france michel dubost évêque émérite
du diocèse d'évry corbeil essonnes
orthodoxes protestants et catholiques
dont tous d'accord pour exprimer leur
défiance vis-à-vis de ce projet de loi
c'est un texte qui qui rassemble dans la
défiance peut craignez vous monsieur
précisément il ya plusieurs à craindre
mais je pense que la première chose à
remarquer c'est d'abord en fait tout
simplement cette tribune vous l'avez dit
qui a été signé par par les trois
représentants des églises chrétiennes
protestantes orthodoxes et catholiques
et c'est finalement dans cette tribune
où on y apprend beaucoup de choses c'est
un petit peu le presque le monde à
l'envers on ne peut dire on à la défense
de la loi de 1905 par les représentants
des cultes alors que bon ça a été un
petit peu compliqué il ya cent ans pour
mettre en place cette loi cette loi a
été mise en place progressivement
elle a été acceptée elle à tout le monde
c'est faire cette loi un bouquet laïcité
dite à la française est aujourd'hui
c'est monseigneur eric de moulins
beaufort et c'est eux et leurs comptes
en banque des protestants et des
orthodoxes qui doivent rappeler au
gouvernement l'importance de cette
laïcité alors que la loi est censée je
suis conforté les principes républicains
donc voilà je pense que le premier pas
le principal problème c'est qu'on fait
de la religion une menace a priori dans
l'espace public
or en fait moi je pense que ce n'est pas
la religion qui est une menace à l'ordre
public mais c'est le fanatisme et si on
cible la religion je pense qu'on
encourage d'une certaine manière le
fanatisme
quand la république vient dire à un
catholique à un chrétien un musulman à
un juif ta religion est un problème pour
moi elle a un problème pour la
république elle est un poème pour les
principes républicains eh bien
finalement on instaure cette méfiance
entre la république et l'évolution filez
donc on tous ces croyants dans les bras
des fanatismes alors que des principes
tout c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait
éviter
alors michel mercier aussi d'être avec
nous avant de vous faire réagir je vous
propose d'écouter françois clavero lee
président de la fédération protestante
de france et que tu es ce qu'il en dit
de cette loi pourquoi viser les
associations cultuelles qui sont
majoritairement protestante et juive
c'est à dire des associations dont les
membres respectent les principes de la
république depuis 115 ans l'accumulation
de mesures de contrôle et de
surveillance et à force de soupçon donne
l'impression d'être issu d'un projet
pour freiner cette vie cultuelle et
c'est en ce sens que nous disons il y un
risque il y à une menace qui pèse sur la
liberté d'exercice du culte par
l'accumulation de ces mesures
non mais c'est lire entre les lignes il
ne faut pas être hypocrite que voulait
dire françois clavero lee pourquoi viser
aussi les juifs et les protestants dans
tout le monde danse on sait que c'est
slam radical qui est visé par par ce
texte le premier ministre mme ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas caché
de fait c'est une loi qui est fait pour
contre le séparatisme des islamiques et
n'est pas faite contre l'islam qui n'est
parfait contrôle du judaïsme contre le
christianisme contre l'islamisme radical
j'ai bien dit c'est très important de le
souligner
j'ai perdu monsieur michel debost
pardonnez moi on sait pour elle de son
jeu je vais me retourner vers un jean
bleu noir elle en espérant que le som
reviennent chez notre évêque émérite du
diocèse d'évry corbeil essonne s'est
toujours pas le cas non manifestement
peut-être un petit à petit c'est son nom
c'est toujours pas le cas de jean benoît
rel c'est vrai voilà ça veut dire un
gros que les juifs les catholiques les
protestants serait d'une certaine
manière froid c'est alors que ce texte
vise de l'aveu même du premier ministre
l'islamisme radical liskamm radical je
pense qu'il faut revenir aussi à
l'origine de ce projet et on voit qu'il
ya une évolution sémantique très
intéressante dans l'origine de ce projet
à la base donc c'était évidemment pour
lutter contre l'islam radical contre
l'islamisme ensuite il a fallu lutter
contre les séparatismes et aujourd'hui
on a une loi qui ne veut finalement plus
rien dire ce qu'il protège
vié censée protéger les principes
républicains on peut absolument plus
rien dire et effectivement le fait de
mettre tout le monde dans le même panier
elle met l'islamisme et le judaïsme de
mettre l'islam radical et les
socialismes dans le même panier on a on
a un problème parce que ya pas de na pas
de fanatisme chrétien n'a pas de faille
de fanatisme catholique c'est quoi un
fanatique catholique c'est quelqu'un qui
va dans le métro et qui dit jésus vous m
donc je pense que il ya une différence
fondamentale entre les religions et
l'islamisme et le gouvernement a du mal
à assumer cette distinction sous la peur
de se faire taxer d'islamophobe on n'a
malheureusement pas toujours toujours
pas récupéré michel dubost ans c'est
pour ça que je me retourne pas vers lui
n'ayez crainte vous êtes seul dans cette
interview
mais ça va très bien on va écouter
justement philippe bas sur ce thème
question du scénar sénateur et
conseiller départemental de la manche
sur cette loi sur le séparatisme vous
espérez faire sortir les salafistes des
mosquées mais alors où iront ils
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
combinaison de la liberté de réunion et
de la liberté d'expression leur
permettent de se tourner vers d'autres
lieux que les mosquées pour reprendre
leur propagande
et si tel devait être le cas nous
serions en quelque sorte mieux protéger
contre l'intrusion du politique dans les
lieux de culte que contre la diffusion
d'une idéologie subversive en dehors des
lieux de culte on risque d'en mettez
tous les cultes sans distinction qui ne
pose aucun problème à la république pour
un résultat qui serait absolument
dérisoires dans notre volonté de faire
reculer le séparatisme jean benoit rlc
bien ça le problème c'est que ce texte
il ratisse trop large il me répond
a finalement aucune dérive c'est
finalement un tas stépan creed
je pense que c'est un texte hypocrite on
peut prendre un exemple très simple
l'exemple du contrôle du financement des
lieux de culte
le projet de loi aujourd'hui alourdit le
fus les procédures du financement des
lieux de culte notamment sur sur les
financements qui viennent de l'extérieur
et il cible à mots cachés évidemment le
financement par les pays étrangers
notamment l'arabie saoudite des mosquées
en france puisque ensuite l on a une
influence à travers cette ce financement
est aujourd'hui on va alourdir les
procédures qui sont des traces et
l'autre pour tous les cultes on va créer
des garanties pour des associations
spécifiquement cultuelle quand d'autres
associations absolument pas toutes ces
garanties
voilà pour un objectif qui est caché on
cible
absolument tout le monde est
effectivement je pense qu'il ya une
certaine hypocrisie dans dans ce projet
de loi cette fois l'église ne saurait pu
délivrer des contraintes de l'état sans
quelque sorte un retour en arrière selon
vous eh bien c'est ce que dit aussi la
tribune c'est à dire que c'est un peu un
retour en arrière au contrôle de type
concordataire c'est à dire le contrôle
qui existait au 19ème siècle on avait un
contrôle dans l'établissement de l'état
sur sur la religion notamment les
catholiques et est donc là on arrive on
revient en tout cas ce système où l'état
s'immisce dans la religion alors que la
laïcité dite à la française était
justement l' inverse c'est à dire que
c'était chacun chez soi la république
s'occupe de la sphère publique
gasquet s'occupe de l'état et la sphère
religieuse s'occupe de la sphère
religieuse est en fait aujourd'hui on
mélange un peu
tout ça et on arrive à interdire des
choses dans l'espace public
l'idée de la laïcité voilà c'est
justement de séparer les deux et
aujourd'hui on mélange tout l'état
l'état veut de s'immiscer veut prendre
le contrôle un petit peu de l'art et de
la religion
généralement pour un souci sécuritaire
mais aussi pour d'autres d'autres
raisons et je pense que le lien il ya un
problème la laïcité à la française elle
a marché pendant 105 ans alors il faut
peut-être l'adapter 1
là tout ce qui dans le projet de loi
aujourd'hui n'est pas mauvais il ya
notamment une lutte contre les mariages
forcés ou compte que les discriminations
voilà donc on a quand même des avancées
qui sont nécessaires et qui sont adaptés
à notre temps aujourd'hui et le
gouvernement malheureusement on va
souvent trop loin dans son contrôle
alors qu'il faudrait juste une
adaptation de cette laïcité de la
l'issue de la loi 1905
on a un bouleversement de cette loi
clairement qu est ce que vous craignez
concrètement qu'est ce qui peut arriver
justement pour les coaches juifs les
cultes chrétiens parce que si on va par
là on peut se dire ben ils vont vous
fichent la paix avec un les contrôles
puisque c'est toi vous le dit l
hypocrite elle vit
en réalité les slams radical alors
évidemment et viser les ciels vise
l'islam radical en fait tout le monde
est touché donc au final il ya quand
même de nombreuses répercussions jeux
cités par exemple le contrôle du
financement qui va alourdir les
procédures il ya aussi au delà de la
simple liberté du culte entre guillemets
et aussi la neutralité de l'enseignement
catholique qui a vomi dans en question
l'enseignement en famille il ya beaucoup
de restrictions sur sur les écoles hors
contrats qui sont qui sont en train
d'être débattue et donc on a en a
véritablement une restriction des
libertés
tout ça pour un souci sécuritaire alors
le souci sécuritaire mon panier il
existe vraiment que ce soit au niveau de
la crise sanitaire au niveau 2 les
violences physiques ont mené comme des
attentats dont il ya un problème
sécuritaire mais il ne peut pas être
l'alpha et l'oméga de toute décision
politique et on sait qu'il ya une
tension entre liberté et sécurité
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement tend à
donner plus de sécurité et donc à
restreindre à restreindre les libertés
et au premier chef la liberté culte
merci en tout cas gens venant à rennes
et on s'excuse auprès de michel dubost
évêque émérite du diocèse d'évry corbeil
essonnes pour problèmes de sons qui nous
a empêchés malheureusement d'avoir un
débat avec vous et d'entendre sa voix en
ce cas merci à lui et surtout merci à
vous un jour bleu noir harel d'avoir été
en direct avec nous on est bien en tout
cas compris ce qui vaut aux chiffonniers
si je peux me permettre dans cette loi
merci à vous